PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Welcome to "Get
Cooking in Cloud," where
we share the best recipes
to apply in your Cloud kitchen.
I'm Priyanka, and
in this episode,
we're wrapping up the mobile
backend app recipe with Jen.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JEN PERSON: It's
bittersweet that this
is our last mobile
app backend recipe.
I've had so much fun
cooking with you.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Ah, well, it's
been great having
you visit my kitchen.
So tell me about
this last recipe.
What are we cooking up today?
JEN PERSON: Today's solution
combines REST or gRPC
with Compute Engine.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Ah,
so the ingredients then,
are some sort of API with REST
or gRPC and Compute Engine?
JEN PERSON: Exactly.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: So I
talked about Compute Engine
in the first season.
I'll link the video below
for any of our viewers
who didn't catch it.
Well, Compute Engine lets you
create and run virtual machines
on Google infrastructure.
You have admin rights to
the server and full control
over its configuration,
but this also
means that you are responsible
for updates and maintenance.
JEN PERSON: Exactly, Priyanka.
Compute Engine gives you
more configuration control
than my previous recipes,
but that puts the onus
on the developer to
monitor and maintain it.
Now there are two
main protocols used
to connect to Compute Engine
instances, REST and gRPC.
Like all of my recipes, the
choice you make here really
depends on your app's
particular needs.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
So I know that Rest
is an architecture
for network app
that uses an HTTP request to
post, read and delete data.
You can build REST APIs on
Compute Engine, the App Engine
standard environment, and the
App Engine flexible environment
instances that your
app can call to access
the backend service you build.
In this case, we're
specifying Compute Engine.
JEN PERSON: Yes.
And gRPC is a
framework that makes
it possible for a mobile
app to directly call
methods on a backend service
as if it were a local object.
gRPC uses the HTTP/2
standard, which
introduces bi-directional
streaming, flow control, header
compression, and the ability
to multiplex requests
over a single TCP connection.
You can use gRPC to make
your mobile app more
bandwidth efficient
and to reduce latency
between your app and backend
service running on GCP.
You can write gRPC
clients and servers
in any of gRPC's
supported languages.
So you could, for instance,
create a gRPC server in Java
with clients in
Go, Python or Ruby.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: That
is great overview of gRPC.
We also talked about REST
and Compute Engine so far.
In which scenario would
you recommend this recipe?
JEN PERSON: I recommend Compute
Engine with REST or gRPC
for porting an existing
backend service running
on an on premises server
or a virtual machine,
and backend services that
require a custom server
or third party libraries.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
So this could be
good solution for
handling my legacy on prem
code for Priyanka's Kitchen.
JEN PERSON: Exactly.
But if your app requires
automatic real time
data synchronization
across devices,
I recommend using one of our
Firebase solutions instead.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: What if I
prefer automatic maintenance
and scaling?
JEN PERSON: Well, then this
isn't the solution for you,
since you must maintain and
upgrade the server yourself,
and you must manually configure
and manage in autoscaler.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Where can developers
learn more about using Compute
Engine with REST or gRPC
in their apps?
JEN PERSON: There is
an end-to-end sample
app called Sticky
Notes that sends text
to the service, which responds
by returning a generated image.
The Sticky Notes sample
is available in both REST
and gRPC versions, so you can
compare the two protocols.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: All right,
Jen, that sounds great.
I cannot wait to take a look
at the Sticky Notes sample app.
That's all for today on
"Get Cooking in Cloud."
With this, we have wrapped up
the mobile app backend recipes
on Google Cloud.
If you would like to know
more about today's recipe
or any of the ones we have
covered in this season,
check out the links in
the description below.
JEN PERSON: If you
like this video,
then check out the other
episodes in the series.
And don't forget to
subscribe to our channel,
so you can be notified
about new episodes
of "Get Cooking in Cloud,"
as well as other great Google
Cloud content.
[MUSIC PLAYING]